hey everyone this is jeremy schieffling
at khan academy i want to wish you a
happy friday after week number five can
you believe it since this all started
i know like the way of doing things in
the past feels like the distant past all
of a sudden but we really appreciate
everything that educators are doing
across the country
to serve their students in this time of
need and we especially appreciate your
fellow educator jessica who's calling in
from brownsville texas where she's an
english and esl teacher
and is using khan academy for the last
two years to serve her students in a
really effective way so jessica thank
you so much for being here today thank
you for inviting me i appreciate it
and just to give folks a sense of how
they can interact with you we're going
to go over some basic things about
jessica's background as an educator how
she recommends that you start using khan
academy if you're just getting started
this week but then if you have specific
questions you can ask those via the go
to webinar questions feature just type
them in and we'll take those as we go
into the session and jessica can really
walk you through whatever's on your mind
so that being said jessica why don't you
tell folks a little bit about your own
uh educational adventure and how you got
to where you are as a teacher today
well i'm an english esl english 1
teacher
in brownsville texas our demographics
are pretty unique we have very high
low socioeconomic students and i also
have a large percentage of esl students
we have 2 500 students in my school we
have six high schools
and out of our 2500 students about 350
of them are eels and we have about a
hundred students who are newcomers
which means that they're at the
beginning level
as far as we can tell from english as
far as english language learning so
they're beginners
i am certified as an esl
english one teacher four through eight
and eight through twelve in texas i also
hold technology application
certifications for eight to twelve
grades eight through twelve
um we are psyop trained we also embed a
lot of technology into our classroom
we're very lucky
to have access as esl teachers to ipads
and google home books
and all the different technology that we
can use so we started using khan academy
about
two years ago in the classroom
and it was pretty interesting because
we found that a lot of our esl students
lacked the basic grammar
and functional english language skills
that we didn't really have time to sit
and teach for long periods of time so we
needed to find a way to kind of embed
those skill sets and those teeks along
with our helps that we are required to
use in texas
by using khan academy and it was really
amazing because
for our newcomers we started off you
know two days a week
for them and they really started picking
up on the grammar basics you know we
went over nouns um
you know verbs we went over punctuation
and we used khan academy
as a way to bridge the gap and because
it was visual
and it allowed them multiple
opportunities to kind of
do the questions without fear of failure
so it was really really great for them
because they were able to see it in a
non-threatening environment
and we also used khan academy because i
do computer science after school with
our esls so khan academy also has really
great programs
if you're looking for some interesting
things in there like they have the pixar
in the box and they also have computer
science so we use it across the board
in our school
district very cool and so
um obviously khan academy has all these
tools and there are all these other
technology platforms out there
but if you were in the shoes of a
teacher who's just starting with
technology or just starting with khan
academy today and trying to serve their
english language learners but now over a
remote distance
are there any tips you would give them
for just getting started serving that
audience
um i i would one is if you do have
access to google classroom
and your isd has logins for your
students you can automatically log them
in to khan academy using google
and when you log them in all they do is
they input
their login credentials from the school
which makes it so much easier to connect
to the actual classroom and then you're
able to give them the class code so that
way they can sync with it um that really
helped us
and we did it in small chunks when we
first started we started 45 minutes a
week and then we expanded to longer
periods of time
but we really focused on the skills that
they were missing
because
we have our yearly start and of course
tests in texas
our data is always pretty current so we
look at what our students were
struggling in and then finding ways to
kind of remedy
those areas in order to strengthen them
for the test so what we found was our
kids really struggled with editing and
revising because they didn't have the
basic
foundational skills
so we started small we started with
nouns and simple sentences and when we
did the simple sentences we would embed
the khan academy for the structure
and then we would
bridge it to a piece of writing and have
them identify nouns verbs they still get
the reading and the writing
and then we were able to do those skills
and move the ones who were
a little more advanced
could move on and the ones who struggled
we were able to identify them more and
be able to work on them one-on-one so
it's about small chunks at first until
you get really comfortable with the
program and i really like that i could
see
and i would go and check hey did you do
so and so assignment and i could see
whether or not they viewed the video i
could see what they got in the
assignment and i would tell them if
you're struggling with the assignment
and you didn't watch the video you
should probably go back and see where
the video
what the video has to say before you
even start the assignment
very cool i think that's such a
important piece of advice right now when
everything feels so overwhelming you
just start small one lesson one
assignment
if your students can sort of get that
experience under their belt before you
move on to the bigger and bolder things
and what's really great is you can you
can start you know if you do nouns for
esl especially um you know you have to
work on the cognates depending on where
their language is where they struggle
luckily we're in an area where most of
our students are spanish-speaking most
of the people here are bilingual but
that's might not be so in other areas um
we also have a population of um
a population that speaks uh tagalon
so with that it's really helpful to use
like we use our duolingo we use our khan
academy we use our flip grid in order to
kind of bridge the language so what we
do is we start with nouns
and then we give an assignment on nouns
so everything connects
together and then we'll give a a star
question that has like
identifier edit
whatever
topic we're working on so everything's
just kind of streamlined
i suppose
very cool
so now we've sort of covered some of the
basics about like how would you get
students registered what would you give
them as the first assignment how would
you look at some of those results let's
dig into some of the
next step questions from the audience
so lisa asks a really important question
which is so much of this is in text and
obviously many ells especially the
newcomers really struggle just getting
started
what do you do to sort of serve them
given this sort of text-based focus of
many of these khan academy questions
so the way we did that also was we used
a variety of
models so that's why it's important to
start small you don't want to give them
too much too fast because it gets very
difficult
we do a lot with dictionaries and we
start this from the i know it's hard
right now
but we make use of all the online
dictionaries so if you have a
spanish-speaking student the best online
dictionary that we have found has been
spanish
dict.com i believe that's the the um
website address it's one of the better
yes that one it's one of the better
spanish english translators and it's one
that our students use all the time
um to translate um some of those
text-based questions um we start
if you're not in too much of a rush you
can start small like a noun is a
sustantivo
so we do a lot of bridging
with the
the primary language because academic
language does take five to seven years
to kind of learn
so we bridge a lot with our with our um
home language which is part of our alps
in texas where we're allowed to use the
home language of the student in order to
bridge those gaps so we try
to at least
kind of um
translate
the main ideas like noun or not a noun
what one problem my kids struggled with
in identifying nouns was when now when
the names were from other countries like
i think there's a couple
names from japan a couple names from
other countries in there so they really
struggled with that because they weren't
used to other names so we had to go over
that so what i would do is i did mini
lessons as i was discussing earlier i do
mini lessons and i upload them to my
youtube so if the students are asking me
questions that i know they're going to
struggle with or a concept instead of
doing a live zoom i do
a mini lesson and then i upload it and
share it
that has been by far the easiest for me
um i i
it's really you can look up cognates
things like that just to help kind of
bridge that gap in the language i'm not
sure what language that your students
speak um just from experience from my my
spanish speaking students
very cool and that actually
that actually speaks to a great question
from paula which is what's the most
user-friendly uh sort of video
engagement tool when you're working with
an esl classroom and it sounds like
instead of trying anything really fancy
or maybe complicated youtube is
something that students are really
familiar with and it's easy for you as a
teacher to quickly record a video on
your phone and then share with them is
that right
yes um
for me i get a little kind of
overwhelmed with everything that
everyone shows like shares like edgy
puzzle and all of these things and i'm
like i don't have time to learn another
platform right now so i've been sticking
to what i i know is like using uh my
phone um i had recently as a lot of my
el students we were doing poetry and
they kept asking me the same question so
really quickly i pulled out my cell
phone i recorded a three minute video
really easy just explaining to them and
showing them what i needed them to do
and then i uploaded it into a private
youtube and then i shared it with them
via my communication app which is what i
use is remind and google classroom since
they're already all in there
because we've been doing a blended
classroom for a while um
so i share it to them and then that way
they're able to access the video on
their own time and
that way they can do it at their own
pace it's really important for esl
students
we have to
let them do it at their own pace even
more so now because the fact that we're
not right next to them that's one of the
most difficult things with this online
learning is not being able to be there
with them to kind of guide them into
what they need to know um so that was
the easiest way for me was doing it
through
video on my cell phone and then just
uploading it
it's not fancy there's no razzle dazzle
but it works
and the other thing you had pointed out
before uh jessica was just that um
especially for low-income students where
there may only be a single device or no
device in the home
synchronous communication may actually
be really difficult especially if there
are siblings there and so that actually
leads to a direct question from amy who
also has a number of low-income students
who only have phones at home not
chromebooks not laptops
how would you recommend that they use
khan academy if at all given that all
they have are their smartphones
that's a really good question so before
they gave me
my newer chromebooks we had like an
older cow and so half the laptops would
work and the other half would just they
just didn't work at all and so what we
did was my student one of my student was
like let's try to download it on your
phone and see what happens so we did and
it is actually mobile friendly you can
download khan academy onto your phone
and you can still assign them lessons
from it and they're able to access it on
their phones which has been a real life
saver
for us too because of the
inaccessibility
to reliable internet or um
chromebooks because we're not a
one-to-one district
we tried to give out as many
chromebooks as we could but we ran out
rather quickly
and the same with the hot spots that we
delivered we ran out of them before we
could give them to every single student
so because we're not one-to-one we do do
a lot of it on mobile and my students
used to turn it in all the time after
school before school some of them would
even use it in class when their laptops
would die so it is very user friendly on
mobile as well
great
um let's see here
alicia is asking a really good question
do you recommend always assigning the
videos or only the activities and the
quizzes themselves and then let let the
kids watch the videos on their own if
they choose to
i always just for my esl
you have to gauge what level your esl
kids are so i have varying levels of esl
students so the ones that are in my
english one sl classes are brand new to
the country they speak very little
english
so for them it's required for them to
watch the video and i only give them one
assignment
and then i look at the data
so once they've done the assignment i
look at their scores and see if they're
ready for like the mastery sections and
then i'll assign those sections
individually or at the same time when i
feel as though they've mastered those um
skill sets because if they're still
scoring in the 60s and 40s and then i
see that i need to go back and maybe do
a mini lesson really quickly
upload it
or assign like a
coordinating text or something where
they can identify nouns or verbs or
comma splices and then that way
i can see where i can remedy those areas
that they're weak on um
i would say for esls that are beginners
it should always be required that they
do the video it's just more beneficial
for them if you have someone who is more
intermediate and advanced you could
probably do
the lessons first and then if they're
struggling with it assign the video
very cool
now a number of teachers including
stephanie are asking um is khan
available in different languages and so
khan is actually available in 44
languages as of this moment so question
for you jessica do you ever have
students especially those newcomers
switch to the spanish language version
of khan academy or do you always have
them use the english version sort of
build that
expertise over time
so what we do for those students is they
actually put the subtitles
they put the spanish subtitles so they
can read it and then listen to it at the
same time again you would have to gauge
where your students are academically
some may come with lower levels of
fluency in their home language with that
you may want to have them watch the
video in both languages
but most of the time they we use these
subtitles
on the videos in order for them to read
it in spanish and hear it in english
great
okay let's see here
um
okay ronetta wants you to really go go
deep here
she's really curious about all these
platforms you mentioned like
spanishdick.com and duolingo
are there other programs that you really
enjoy using and that you would recommend
to fellow educators in this moment
um we also use flipgrid a lot in the esl
classrooms and we use nearpod
for flipgrid i really like flipgrid
because we have a standardized test at
the end of the year that tests our
english
secondary learners
every year
uh when they're enrolled in texas school
it's called the telpas
and in the telpas they have a speaking
portion so we use flipgrid and we'll ask
them questions
based on the questions they'll ask them
in the tel pas sometimes it's tell me a
story
tell me what they're doing in this
procedural and so it really helps them
get used to speaking in english and
being able to take that test at the end
of the year
so we use that duolingo
yeah we also are yeah i'm thinking wait
wait there's so many do you think
would be a good thing at this point
um
if you haven't done it probably not but
it's something you could look into for
the following year but flipgrid
definitely
definitely is a great tool so if the
kids can't share their writing they're
more than likely to gonna try to speak
and you can what i like about flipgrid
too is you can um
moderate the videos so nobody else can
see them but you
absolutely
esl kids are nervous about speaking
yeah and i'll just say like having um a
couple kids at home myself i know that
flipgrid is such a great way to keep the
lines of communication open because it
really creates this back and forth
pattern of engaging with the educator
and the family at home so just a nice
way to sort of let them know you're
you're still there and thinking of them
um
speaking of next year i know that we're
very much focused on the here and now
how do we get through the next hour how
do we get through the day how do we get
to next week
but for educators who are already
thinking about whoa we're going to have
a lot of students with a lot of gaps
heading into september
is there any way for data to carry over
from khan academy this year to the
students khan academy account for next
year so that data can be used in
subsequent years this is a question from
clarissa
i think it should be because you you're
they're logged into your classroom
um so sometimes what we do is before
they even leave is we'll take all that
data out
and because they're esl kids we actually
have like our lpac committee and so we
use a lot of that data and so we give it
to the next teacher
so
before they leave us we're able to give
the the next teacher all their data
their test scores their khan academy
everything that they have until you
delete that they they stay in there but
i'm not
i've never had it transfer over and
that's probably something i should ask
but our school's really big it's like
2500 students and a lot of teachers and
i've never really asked the english
teacher i feel kind of bad now because
i'm like maybe i should go ask her
oh yeah absolutely definitely check out
check with her i will mention that like
technologically it's totally feasible
yeah it's totally feasible as jessica
mentioned the very beginning is that
your student is creating an account with
their school email or their google
classroom login or whatever and that
single account can be logged into
multiple classes on khan academy at once
yeah and as long as you don't archive it
or delete it it should still be there
yeah so if you come into the learner
view which you can always see from your
name in the upper right-hand corner you
can actually join multiple classes
so your ell class your um
science class your math class all those
teachers can be working with a single
student account and that data can be
shared as jessica mentioned and i will
also say it's not just for english a lot
of our biology teachers who teach our
esls we also use khan academy for
biology we use it for algebra
we use it for
uh sat prep so
it's not just for for the grammar
sections we also use it in other core
content areas within our school
very cool for our esls
yeah i will mention that
con not only has a broad sort of range
of content we're actually the official
partner with the college board on sat so
for the students who are all freaking
out about the canceled exams and how do
i stay sharp that's always available and
that's that's been blessed by the folks
who make the sat themselves
and we do have some el students in our
ap sections
um and we have them practice the sat and
act through khan academy
very cool now speaking of all this
content um amy really wants to get into
the specifics
do you recommend any particular units or
lessons or exercises that would be
really effective for ells
and to add a little more context amy
actually works with adult ells just
trying to figure out what of all this
content might be most useful
that's really interesting because we did
host a few adult esl classes
at our school for
about maybe six weeks
and so we used it
again what we did was we did a pre-test
so always start with some sort of
pre-test in order for you to gauge where
they're at
because you don't want to start too low
or too high because either they'll get
bored or they get frustrated so we give
a pre-test out and from that pre-test we
can see
where they can start at
what skills that they can use i mainly
start from like concrete and abstract
nouns because those are some of the most
difficult
um
kind of
things that the el students are having
trouble with is the concrete and
abstract nouns also they have a lot of
trouble with a foreign endings
which is on i believe on the grammar
sections and so we start with those
first so they can have an idea of what
to use also conjunctions they really
struggle with conjunctions as well
cool i hope that helps
that uh every single course on khan
academy has this course challenge at the
very end so again
in this case i clicked into the grammar
course i scrolled all the way down to
the bottom
and you can assign this course challenge
as an easy way to sort of get
pre-testing for here's where folks are
and then when you go back to actually
assign specific pieces of content you
can really use that to inform a very
differentiated approach so just like
jessica mentioned if you know some folks
are very much advanced some books are
just beginning you can assign not to
your entire class but the specific
students these are the ones who need
this material here are the others who
need something different
very important question for chris uh is
khan academy free or does our school
need to buy licenses to access all this
material
no khan academy is free
and so you can get your kids started
right away um you don't need licenses
they can access it from anywhere that's
what i really loved about it was that it
was such an open access concept and it
was really beneficial for our students
and for our district we have 50 000
students in our district so it can it
can get pricey for us as well
yeah absolutely and just to be clear
this is not one of those like free until
the end of the school year until the end
of the crisis khan academy is actually
not profit so as long as we keep
fundraising money there will be free
academy for every teacher and every
student yes
okay here we go
this is an interesting question so
justin says i teach u.s history to high
school students and their native
language is chinese
they are an eld one and two
what sites would you suggest especially
now
that given everything that's happening
and how do you recommend they use con
so thinking about maybe
uh that kind of audience specifically
focused on social studies any tips you
might give justin
i'm trying to think of ld is that like a
beginner
yeah i think that's what he's getting at
oh okay okay and obviously there is a
u.s history course in khan academy but
it is fairly like english heavy so maybe
that's what he's speaking to
so when you have really english heavy
things the best thing to do is just
chunk everything you don't want to give
them too much too fast so if you're
going to go over something even if you
give them a passage to do
you want to chunk that and the same
would go for using things like this so
you want to give them key vocabulary
ahead of time even while using the
online platform so if you were to take a
look at what jeremy has pulled up where
it says like things like continent
history north american what you want to
do is you want to give them those words
ahead of time and have them try and
translate it
because you'd be surprised how many el
students already have their own
translators my students are constantly
missed kennedy's terms and i'm like no
you have to use the dictionary because
the test requires a dictionary but um so
what we do is we have them
kind of
showcase those main vocabulary points so
when they go in they kind of already
have an idea of what the content is
going to be about
that's part of the psyop method
where you're able to give them the key
vocabulary and keep focusing on those
key vocabularies and that key concept in
small chunks and still be able to use
like maybe one or two questions
you know from it and and then that way
they know exactly at least those key
ideas it's not per
perfect but it allows them an
opportunity to gain more academic
language
and it's just you know using
pre-vocabulary strategies to help them
kind of bridge their gap um
when speaking another language
i hope that was helpful
and i think that actually integrates
perfectly into this really important
like high-level question from pramall
which is this is a difficult thing even
in regular times but in these abnormal
times we find ourselves in
how do you create a productive struggle
for students how do you balance the
desire to translate everything for them
with the need for them to grapple with
english are there any tools or
strategies you recommend to find that
balance
so um because in texas we do have our
alps and so from the beginning of the
year to the end of the year we have this
timeline that allows us
to use primary home language and then
kind of weed them off of those
translations so at the beginning of the
year it's 80 20.
um but and then we go into and when we
say 80 20 it's not bilingual because in
the secondary sections
um the secondary high school levels uh
middle schools we don't
do bilingual so that makes sense it's
kind of like okay this is road but you
say kaye all right what is gaia it's
road so we allow them to make we allow
them to bridge l1 to l2
um so we start them off with that
bridging but we work a lot on cognates
and this is just spanish but you could
probably do it in other languages too
you find the commonly used words that
you're going to be using within your
classroom
so if you teach math what is the common
vocabulary you're going to be using all
the time that common vocabulary needs to
be used constantly you need to be saying
it so they can hear how you say it so
they can know what it means a lot of
visuals
um a lot of of of uh you know when you
when you're using a concept you put it
up on pipe i know you can't do that
right now because it's online but you
can also do it in a video where you just
kind of keep going over those same
concepts so they can get the lesson
and and you chunk the answers you chunk
the questions you chunk the readings and
then as they get further along you start
expanding to to more rigorous
instruction um and and that's why we do
so much at the beginning of the year
with khan academy so they can kind of
bridge that language and we're there to
help them we have their dictionaries
there we take vocabulary lists so that
way by the time we get to this point in
the year we've already gone to english
only
got it great advice
i know we're almost at time here and
there's still many more questions out
there so one last question for you
jessica
is if you want to get support on khan
academy either how to use a specific
piece of the site or talk to other
educators are there any resources you
would recommend to get those questions
answered
uh yes um there is a facebook group for
khan academy educators and you can ask
questions in there
there are a lot of ambassadors also
online on twitter who will give you
advice and and be able to help
troubleshoot
the khan academy for teachers page
though is extremely beneficial
there's tons of teachers who are
answering questions and asking questions
and it's a great way to connect with
people who have already been using khan
academy for a long period of time and
those who have just started
great
i'll also just mention very quickly here
um those are all volunteer educators
just like jessica who are going above
and beyond right now to help out
if you ever have a very technical
question and you want that answer by
khan academy staff just go up to your
name in the upper right hand corner
come down here to the help section and
then all you have to do is save report a
problem it doesn't have to be a formal
technical bug but just a question about
how to get something done
send that in and let us know and we'll
respond back there so jessica i know
we're at time i want to thank you so
much for making time to share your
expertise today and pay it forward to
the next generation of con teachers and
i want to thank everyone else out there
for making time out of their busy
schedules to invest in this session
and i want to thank everybody for trying
their hardest during this difficult time
and working with the el students it's
you're doing such great work
and
you're
in the right place to help them and khan
academy can help you do that
wonderful oh those words let's head into
a well-deserved weekend
thank you all for everything you're
doing right now to make your students
lives a little brighter and thank you
again jessica for making us all a little
smarter this afternoon have a great
weekend